[Music]
well what do we have here he burned his
hand on a stove did you warn him not to
touch a hot stove of course I did well
I'm afraid we can't help him clearly he
did this to himself
[Music]
that's absurd isn't it that a doctor
would compromise care for a patient
because he did it to himself
but unfortunately overweight and obese
people are the victims of this kind of
irrational weight prejudice almost every
day whether it's in the form of negative
attitudes societal stigma or unfair
treatment
[Music]
my name is Emmy and as the first
plus-size supermodel trust me I know
what it's like to be judged based on my
size and that's why I'm here today to
raise your awareness of exactly what
weight bias is how it shows up in
medical practices and who its victims
sources and consequences are I'm hopeful
that by the time that we come to the end
of this brief journey you'll be inspired
to make subtle the critical changes in
your own medical practice and perhaps
even adjust your own perceptions and
treatment of your overweight and obese
patients weight stigma is bias and
discrimination aimed at overweight
people based on a series of social
attitudes that people develop they can
start very early in life that assume
that there's something wrong with
overweight people and that they should
be punished for their condition
[Music]
hi could you help me do you have an
appointment yes I made it a year ago
named Cole Natasha
mm-hmm you can take a seat over a year
ago she was really coming to the doctor
one important area where weight bias is
expressed is in medical care overweight
people are very often reluctant to go
get medical care preventive services in
particular because of biased attitudes
they feel that they're going to
encounter at the hands of health care
professionals
there have been studies with physicians
with medical students when nurses with
dieticians with psychologists and with
other healthcare professionals showing
quite negative attitudes and feelings
that there's something wrong with the
overweight person that their weight
condition is that their fault and that
because they haven't lost weight there's
something seriously lacking in their
personality
[Music]
weight bias can be as hurtful and
difficult to counter as racial prejudice
and yet there's no anti-discrimination
laws to protect people who are
overweight weight bias is so prevalent
in our society that most people don't
even stop to question it as a result
overweight individuals confront negative
stereotypes and Prejudice often on a
daily basis it's important to recognize
just how common this problem is in the
United States we recently examined a
nationally representative sample of
American adults and found that the
prevalence of weight discrimination is
comparable to racial discrimination and
has in fact more common and racial
discrimination among women we also found
that the prevalence of weight
discrimination is more common than
discrimination due to ethnicity religion
a sexual orientation or physical
disability it's important to consider
that statistically six out of ten
patients in your waiting room are
already overweight or obese and that
number is rapidly on the rise and most
of you know that obesity has doubled in
the past 20 years in both children and
adults and frightening Lee it's tripled
in teens one in five children is
overweight and overweight children tend
to become overweight adults 30% of
adults are obese and were right on track
for this trend to continue whether or
not you want to deal with this the
obesity epidemic is increasingly going
to impact your practice and as these
numbers continue to grow anything you
can do to make your overweight and obese
patients feel more comfortable and
accepted will translate into an improved
work environment and a more successful
practice and most importantly better
health outcomes for your patients miss
Cole the nurse will take you in
the stigma of obesity is so strong that
even health care professionals
specializing in the treatment of obesity
hold negative attitudes towards the
obese and infer that these people have
blameworthy behavior step on the scale
please I'd rather not we have to weigh
you it's the same as last time we need
it for our medical records
[Music]
260 pounds what are you 5'4 you've
gained weight since last year it looks
like your diet isn't working
please move into the examination room
the doctor will be right with you how
hard is it to push yourself away from
the table and now and get off the couch
nothing to it but to do it you got to
work hard to get that overweight
physicians limit their interactions with
obese patients are ambivalent about
treatment roles and are reluctant to
perform certain screenings studies have
revealed that nurses to view obese
patients as lazy over indulgent
non-compliant and less successful than
their average weight counterparts nurses
self-reported alarming statistics one
study found that in third to half of the
nurses surveyed admitted feeling
uncomfortable caring for obese patients
many would prefer not to touch of these
patients 1/4 of them agree that obese
patients repulsed them and fully a third
would prefer not to care for obese
patients at all and these are their
caregivers this thing isn't big enough
for you
[Music]
here change into this
say whenever the extra-large blood
pressure comas
[Music]
so weight bias could affect an
individual's health in many ways just
being the victim of discrimination could
affect your health but then you add to
that the fact that people don't get care
as they should because of the biased
attitudes they expect to encounter
creates a real problem health care
providers are not immune to weight bias
and unfortunately many overweight and
obese patients report negative
experiences from multiple groups of
providers as an example we surveyed over
2400 overweight and obese adults and we
asked them to tell us about the
different sources of weight bias in
their lives what we found is that
physicians or the second most common
source of weight bias reported fully 69
percent of people reported weight bias
from physicians 46 percent from nurses
37% from dieticians and 21 percent from
mental health professionals so this
really is a common experience for many
individuals in the health care
environment let's take a look at the
impact of all of this to see why this is
such a critical and urgent issue well
there are a range of negative
consequences of weight bias for both
emotional and physical health for
example we know that individuals who
experience weigh bias are more
vulnerable to depression low self-esteem
poor body image and even suicidal
behaviors we also know that individuals
who experience weight bias are more
likely to engage in unhealthy eating
behaviors like binge eating and avoiding
physical activity both of which may
ultimately only reinforce weight gain in
additional obesity it's not a leap to
conclude that when patients experience
bias their preventive care is
compromised
so what's the solution what can you do
the solutions are so simple treat your
overweight and obese patients with the
same courtesy you treat all of your
other patients this is Cole how are you
today good idea here for your 10:30
appointment I share I am great just take
a seat the doctor will see you shortly
thank you there are a number of things
that health professionals and medical
offices can do to combat weight bias the
first is just to take a look at the
physical environment of the
office so for example making sure that
in the waiting room there's room for
people to move around that there are
chairs that are large enough to
accommodate all patients and it's
important to even look at the reading
material in the office because things
like you know fashion magazines that
have a lot of very stereotypical images
of women and exaggerated images of you
know female beauty can sometimes be
disturbing to patients feeling like
they're you know constantly surrounded
by those images
another thing that medical professionals
can do is make sure that the place where
they way patients is private so we
recommend that the scale is off in a
separate section of the office it's not
visible to other people and another
thing that helps a lot is to actually
ask the patient if they would like to be
weighed it's a way of showing respect
for the patient's decision whether or
not they feel that that's important for
them to do during that visit hello would
you like to be weighed today no there
haven't been any significant changes
fair enough there's a gown right there
and I'll be right back to take your
blood pressure great provide larger
sized gowns larger sturdier examination
tables provide larger blood pressure
cuffs to your patients who require a
larger size it's very important for
healthcare providers to increase
awareness about their own attitudes and
assumptions based on weight and
providers can ask themselves questions
like do I make assumptions based on
weight regarding a person's character or
intelligence or success or lifestyle am
i comfortable working with patients of
all sizes do I give appropriate feedback
to encourage helpful behavior change am
I sensitive to the needs and concerns of
obese individuals do I treat the
individual or only the condition another
important aspect of reducing weight bias
is to really understand the complexity
of obesity people think that for someone
who's overweight all they need to lose
weight is some self-control and trying
harder to eat less and exercise more if
that only worked we wouldn't have the
problem that we have today
the causes of obesity are very complex
it is a combination of genetic factors
environmental factors psychological
factors and it's important to recognize
that so that when we look at someone and
we see whatever their body weight is we
don't make assumptions about their
behaviors based on that information it's
important for providers to recognize
that patients may have had negative
experiences with weight bias from
previous providers and so when they come
into the office for the first time
providers need to be aware of these
issues we often hear from patients that
when they go in to the doctor for a
problem such as an earache that the
doctor frequently will blame the issue
on their body weight even though it has
nothing to do with the presenting
problem many patients have tried to lose
weight repeatedly in the past but have
been unsuccessful and so when a patient
comes into the office for the first time
telling a patient that they need to lose
weight is something that the patient has
probably heard many times before and is
not necessarily the most helpful advice
to give
[Music]
one thing that providers can do is to
really emphasize behavior changes rather
than just the number on the scale we
want to be setting goals for patients
that are realistic and achievable so
things like can they increase their
consumption of fruits and vegetables
reduce intake of soda walk more
frequently during the day very tangible
strategies and goals that patients can
work on to improve their health it's
also important for providers to
recognize that relatively small weight
losses can have important improvements
for overall health and so even if an
individual is able to lose five or ten
percent of their body weight that can
have very important implications for the
overall health they may be able to get
off certain medications or to lower
their blood pressure and communicating
this to patients can be very empowering
as they try to make behavior changes if
weight loss was easy we would not have
the current obesity epidemic that we
have and so it's very important for
providers to acknowledge how difficult
this is and to provide support patients
are three times more likely to address
diet and lifestyle changes if their
doctor constructively and sensitively
calls their weight to their attention
yet less than half of physicians
actually do well mrs. Koll all your
vitals look great it sounds like you're
doing great would you mind if we talked
about your weight sure I know I could
eat better get more exercise I'm glad to
hear you're thinking about ways to
improve your health but it's important
to remember that body weight is only
partly determined by diet and exercise
still we can all stand to make lifestyle
improvements let's talk about when
you're doing now how effective that is
okay the medical community offers great
opportunity to help address the issue of
weight bias because with positive
attitudes people will get better care
but not only that but it'll be modeling
for
the world about how overweight people
should be treated and what weight is it
shows that weight isn't is an issue that
needs to be dealt with in medical
settings in a straightforward positive
constructive way and as people see this
then they see that weight isn't an issue
that where there should be tremendous
prejudice and stigma directed in
individuals rather it should be a
straightforward medical condition just
like anything else
in spite of millions of dollars spent
every year on weight loss efforts long
term results in America point to the
fact that there are obviously other
factors at play beyond intention and
commitment yet the increasing prevalence
of obesity in our society has oddly not
reduced weight bias with more and more
people overweight one might think
tolerance would increase but it hasn't
at the Rudd Center we work hard to
eliminate the problem of a weight bias
we believe that there's a strong social
injustice occurring here that hundreds
of millions of people around the world
are deeply affected by this and it just
doesn't need to occur race bias doesn't
need to occur gender bias doesn't need
to occur and weight bias doesn't need to
occur thank you for taking the time to
watch this educational video on weight
stigma for more information please visit
the Rudd Center for Food Policy and
obesity at Yale red center org
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]